محمد القصف هذه الليله طال العاصمه صنعاء
طال عمران طال حجه طال تعز
والحديده نعم نحن نتحدث عن ما يقارب حسب
ما ذكرت اربع اربع مدن
فحجه لم نعرف بالضبط ما ما تم استهدافه
فقط حسب المعلومات الاخيره انه استهدف عبس
ففي البارحه كان هناك استهداف لمنطقه عبس
مكثف كانت هي المنطقه الوحيده التي استهدف
فيها الطيران الامريكي البريطاني استهدف
في تلك المنطقه استهدف مديريه الجر وهي
منطقه زراعيه
كبيره تتواجد فيها مساحات شاسعه من
المناطق الزراعيه
ف لا يعرف ماذا بالضبط استهدف هناك فليس
هناك معسكرات معروفه محدده في تلك الاماكن
هذه الليله حسب ما ذكرت استهدف في تعز
مديريتي حيثان وايضا البرح ب 11 غاره
استهدف جبل عطان بما يقارب خمس غارات
استهدف ايضا بغارتين النهدين وهي من
الجبال المحيطه في في العاصمه صنعاء ولا
ولا تعتبر بانها مناطق بعيده او خارج اطار
صنعاء ولكنها ايضا تقع في قلب قلب مدينه
صنعاء وايضا استهدف الحف في جبل جبل نقم
فهذه الغارات من ضمنها ايضا ما ذكرنا في
الحديده استهدف في استهدف
مديريتي مديريتي اللحيه وايضا الدريهمي
وهي من المدن الساحليه او البلدات
الساحليه التي تقع بالقرب من ساحل البحر
الاحمر
فكلها تعتبر من المحاولات التي يقوم بها
الطيران الامريكي البريطاني بعد تقييمه
ودراسته للاهداف السابقه يحاول الان يضيف
اهداف جديده هنا نتحدث عن عطان و ونتحدث
عن نهدين وهي تعتبر من الاهداف الجديده
وايضا في تعز ما قام به من 11 غاله وهي
استهداف البرح واضا جبل حيثان